alen Haba just can't stop screwing up
when the New York Post reported that
egene Carrol's lawyer Roberta Kaplan had
once worked at the same law firm as
judge Lewis Kaplan habba just had to be
clowning herself some more the two
Kaplan are not related but anonymous
source told the post that judge Kaplan
had been Robbie kaplan's Mentor HBA
dashed off a letter to the judge stating
that quote if there was a mentor mentee
relationship that fact should have been
disclosed Roberta Kaplan said she had no
memories of ever interacting with Lis
Kaplan when they worked at the law firm
Paul Weiss and she brought receipts
showing that her employment histories
were a matter of public record long
before hob figured it out she then
lowered the boom quote on that regard
it's telling that the article in the New
York Post only appeared after Miss hoba
statement referring to a conflict of
interest that is insane and so
incestuous so Roberta Kaplan is
suggesting that habba made up the story
herself and then threatened to pursue
sanctions against habba for trying to
quote push a false Narrative of judicial
bias so that they could characterize any
jury verdict against Trump as the
product of a corrupt system Haba then
sent a second letter backing down and
saying she was just asking questions
that the matter was resolved which
reminds me if you need a great lawyer my
firm the eagle team can take care of it
just click below